[Music]
hi everyone I'm Mike Fisher I'm the CTO
at Etsy thanks for joining me today so
I've been at sea about a year before
that I ran a consultancy for about ten
years and one of my clients happened to
be at sea so I've known them for a very
long time and I'm excited to share the
story about Etsy and move it to the
cloud with you today so that sees the
global marketplace if you're not
familiar with us we have 2 million
creative entrepreneurs that are
connected to over 35 million active
buyers through the 50 million unique
items that they make and these are
artisans and craftspeople who hand make
items or collect vintage items and sell
them to the buyers we see ourselves in a
marketplace as a force for good that in
the US where only 40 percent of
entrepreneurs are women the creative
entrepreneurs at Etsy are over 87% most
of them work from home because they're
artists and craftspeople they turn their
extra bedroom their kitchen table the
garage into their studios and workplaces
and our sellers are really the heart of
Etsy and the products that they make and
I'm going to share with you a quick
video about one of our sellers Dianne
North who I find very inspiring about
the care and and what she puts into
making Etsy's products
[Music]
I think about my sheep like 24 hours a
day
what makes my blanket special is that
there's an animal husbandry side of what
I do
right now on have 46 sheep see we got
Eddie and Rudy cricket and Joan Jane and
then there's Teddy I raise the shape and
keep them their whole lives and the wool
is grown here on I'll go out in the
morning and tend to the animals trimming
their feet feeding them sharing the once
a year when I'm dyeing wool I use all
plant dies it is a full-time job
I grew up on a farm and then I went to
college and studied fashion design
thinking I wanted to go to a big city
and by the end of college I just had
decided that leaving with what I wanted
to do and having a sheep farm and
raising my own wolf was my goal since
Eddie came along its revolutionize
crafting because it reaches a real
worldwide audience I could be here at
home work from my basement then I can
reach a customer that's all over the
world
okay
we are living in a time when people care
about where their food and their items
their crafts come from the blankets are
woven on a traditional room
without electricity everything is
powered by my hands and feet this is
what I imagined when
I was in college and I started to think
about farm life so hopefully that gave
you a sense of the type of care that our
sellers put into their products and how
much they really means to them and so
that's what we find the power of the
marketplace is to be able to enable
these creative entrepreneurs well we not
only see that the power that we can do
good for our sellers but also for our
employees again you know in a world
where we only see 14% women engineers in
the industry that sees a leader that we
see over 30% of our engineers are women
and if you increase that for the entire
technology team it's it's much higher
than that five out of eight of our
executive team are women and we have
gender parity across our board and so
not only do we see ourselves you know as
a force for good in the world but we
also think that we can do good for our
employees last fall we announced our
mission of keep commerce human and you
know a lot of companies try to use
technology to replace people but as Etsy
we see the mission as using technology
to enable people to connect with each
other and to you know to augment that
that relationship and their tasks that
they do you know and whether that's
connecting a seller to a buyer and
trying to eliminate the the currency
issues or the communication issues or
the shipping issues across the world or
trying to empower an employee to help
fight fraud you know we see technology
is augmenting this instead of replacing
and in a world of increasing automation
and commoditization creativity can't be
automated and that human connection
really cannot be commoditized so this is
what drew me to Etsy is the ability to
use two things that I love which is
helping support entrepreneurs and apply
technology and it's the combination of
those two things that brought me to Etsy
and keep all of us motivated each day to
continue working for the sellers and
buyers
now that's the engineering side
mentioned I've known them for a number
of years they've always had a really
strong engineering culture and we were
very innovative in the early years in
some of the areas that like see ICD so
we're one of the early places that the
continuous integration could use
deployment DevOps the concept of
monitoring everything all of these were
early early concepts that Etsy
participated in and at the time there
weren't a lot of tools and so they
developed them the analogy would be that
if we were building our house that we
actually went out and cut down the trees
and hands you the logs and really you
know made our own floors like the
Pioneers and when I came on board a year
ago one of the first tasks that our CEO
asked me to look at was should we be in
some of these areas again should we be
you know hand building our own
monitoring stocks and one of the things
that I looked at first because it was
such a big part of our organization was
the infrastructure so we're still in
data centers in a lot of cases still
running on bare metal and so I took a
look at that and said you know is this
really where we should be constant our
engineering efforts are we in a world
now that we can leverage a partner to do
this with and so this started us down
the cloud path to look at can we find a
vendor who could partner with us and
support us and let us concentrate on
helping the sellers and buyers and so
continuing that analogy of the house you
know we're in a world now where you can
hire an architect and you know and the
subcontractors and stuff did build that
house for us and so this is what we you
know we looked at the cloud journey
about a year ago it said let's start
down that path and let's figure out who
we could partner with
now a lot of the things that make a
unique and special also make it
incredibly challenging from a technology
perspective so all of those 50 million
items are unique handmade creative we
like to think of it sometimes as the
world's largest flash sale and that once
that item is sold there's often not
another item like it we also have
unstructured data so we don't have a
structured listing where we don't have
SKUs we don't have the catalogs and
things like that that a lot of our
products fall into that a typical
ecommerce company would have and so
because of that it makes a lot of things
challenging in terms of finding that
right item for those buyers and to
search all 50 million items so lots of
challenges and of course we're a global
company
we're in almost every country of the
world and so connecting the sellers
across that to sell their products to
communicate to transfer currencies to
ship those products all of those make
our jobs really really challenging but
that's what's fun about it one of the
areas that is specifically challenging
because of this data is search so in a
typical search algorithm that's using
tf-idf we look at the you know the
titles the tags the descriptions things
like that but the challenge is that
those sellers like day and Hort can
describe the wool blankets any way that
she wants she can talk in her
description about the sheep and how she
raised them and how she's you know but
someone else who's making another wool
blanket might call it something very
different and so that makes you really
really challenging for a typical search
you know solar index or stuff like that
to find the right results and so this is
one of the areas that we found that we
could apply machine learning onto to
provide better results for the sellers
and so in or something that we call csr
which is contact specific ranking so
Etsy generates almost a billion over a
billion events a day for their buyers so
the buyers are clicking they're looking
to stuff their favoriting they're out of
the car they're purchasing things all of
that data gets processed and we can use
that
in our machine learning algorithms to
rear ank the search results so that the
results end up being exactly what the
buyers are looking for and not a
combination of everything that's
possible out there so this is an example
of that on the Left you'll see a typical
search result for alarm clocks in this
case but on etsy when you search for
alarm clocks you might be looking for an
actual alarm clock you also might be
looking for parts to an alarm clock that
you want to put in a piece of art that
you're making or you might be looking
for stickers of alarm clocks you might
be looking for prints there's no telling
what you you know are really looking for
and so inner CS are on the right-hand
side where we've taken all of the
queries that happen days and days before
and looked at what the users interacted
with and we apply that back and rewrite
the search results and with that we have
something that the user finds as a
better search result and we see this in
the data of conversions at the number of
pages they have to chant you know to
process do under search and all this and
all of that leads us to show that it's a
better result for the buyers
another example is wedding gowns that on
Etsy you may be looking for the material
to actually to actually sew or make your
wedding gown you can also be looking for
bridesmaids gifts or wedding gown
hangers or any other number of items
when you search for wedding gowns and so
with CSR we can actually apply machine
learning on top of those search results
and produce a better result for the
buyer but all of this as I mentioned
takes a lot of data and a lot of compute
capacity in fact you know that 1.2
billion results sometimes you know it
can take almost 24 hours to process that
data and you know if we train our
algorithms on more than a couple of
weeks with the data we run into capacity
issues and so if you're at a traditional
data center which we have done you know
this cycle that you have to plan in
budget months and months ahead of time
and then you have to order stuff
depending if you're doing large orders
maybe even you know a number of months
ahead and then you need to receive it
you need to rack it you need to set it
up and finally you can actually let the
developers have access to it and so this
cycle is really not conducive if you
want to do fast and really flexible
changes in the machine learning the data
the feature set the feature engineering
all of that that we want to have a
really high cycle cycle time on is it
very conducive but we also want to use
this in a sustainable way
if we didn't keep commerce human in
everything we do meaning the way we do
our compute power to the way that we
consume food and you know energy in our
offices the way we heat and cool our
offices if we didn't do it in a
sustainable fashion you know way it
wouldn't be the way that it wouldn't be
in a way that we're keeping Congress
human and so sustainability is a really
big deal for us and so we've got to look
at not only how do we get a lot more
compute capacity very flexibly but in a
sustainable fashion so this graph in the
upper left is a typical sort of
e-commerce cycle even though we're
global you know the US is one of our
largest markets and this is its typical
cycle of the early evening hours you
know traffic isn't as great it spikes up
you see the dip when everyone sort of
travels home commutes home and then you
know while they're watching TV at night
they're shopping on that seat overall
the right is the idle time of our web
servers and it's about inverse of this
so when the site gets very busy we start
to reduce the the CPU idle when the site
isn't so busy we get upwards of 90
percent idle now the interesting thing
is this is our energy consumption in our
data center and you'll notice that it's
flat because we don't have you know a
virtual environment where we can share
with someone else
we can't when we're not using that give
it back we don't shut down the servers
what's there indoor in and so this isn't
a very sustainable way to provide
compute capacity for the marketplace
and we care about this so much we have
publicly stated our goals around have an
ecological impact that we want a hundred
percent renewable energy in the offices
and in the data centers and everything
that are in our compute by 2020 and we
want to reduce the intensity of this by
25 percent by 2025 and the majority that
is our compute it's taken up by the data
center and so that that is a very big
goal of the engineering team at Etsy is
to focus on that and of course we have
other ecological impact goals that we've
announced and so enter the cloud the
cloud allows us the flexibility the
compute power that we need all of this
to do it in a sustainable way and so
that's what started us on the journey to
look at cloud the other thing is we
mentioned we're a global company and you
know as you know performance matters on
ecommerce sites on search engines all of
this what you'll see is page load times
across different countries we've
highlighted a couple here for Brazil and
India and you'll see that they spiked up
and have really really terrible load
times you know Google's own research
shows that just increasing from 1 to 3
seconds and you get a 32 percent
increase in bounce rate and if you
increase it over 10 seconds you get a
hundred 30-some percent bounce rate and
so this is really important to us that
when we're trying to allow sellers and
buyers across the world to connect to
each other we have to have really fast
performance and having our data centers
located in the US you know doesn't help
us with this even though we use CD ends
- you know for our static content we
have a lot of dynamic content that we
need to generate in the data centers or
on site and so having a global presence
with them provide a cloud provider
really is going to enable us to improve
our performance and so the decision was
made that we're gonna look for a cloud
provider partner but we really wanted
one that fit with our culture as I
mentioned Etsy has a really strong
engineering culture then we wanted one
that we could partner with and really
really believe that they get our culture
we wanted one the focus on machine
learning
you know I describe the marketplace
really as an iceberg and the marketplace
is the tip of the iceberg and behind it
what you don't see is all of those
billion events that get processed every
single day in our big data
infrastructure and then all of that
machine learning that we you know I
mentioned one small application of it
but we're applying it in lots of ways
and we're gonna keep applying it more
and more and so we wanted someone who
had a real focus on machine learning we
also one of those international data
centers so that we can have points of
presidents around the world and then of
course that strong commitment to
environmental sustainability we want
someone who really understood what we
meant and how we felt about it and could
partner with that so the question was
well how do you decide who fits all of
these criteria so we took one big
project of migrate to the cloud and
broke it out into a bunch of smaller
projects and we have you know even
though it's a single marketplace we have
hundreds of systems within the
marketplace and within the Big Data the
machine learning and all of these that
power that and so we broke that into all
of these sub projects we used a racy
model to assign ownership of those and
we asked those owners to take that
vision of that system through an
architecture review some of these
systems were going to be ported lifted
and shifted some of them are gonna use
new technologies some of them were gonna
be redesigned completely to be cloud
ready
and so we one of the owners of these
systems to take through the architecture
review process and what came out of that
is a set of requirements thousands of
requirements from all of these sub
projects of what they would need going
to the cloud and out of the datacenter
and so we took all of those and used a
tool called a decision matrix we put all
the requirements into the decision
matrix and then we worked with our cloud
providers to do experiments and to do
lots of technical meetings and
architecture reviews with the different
cloud providers to get their input on
how best to design and implement our
systems but this decision matrix look
something like this
across the top we have our functional
requirements these are the things that
are overarching ly important to our
business the relationship the cost the
ease of use the value-added services
security locations all of these are
things that are really really important
and they're kind of overarching
requirements and then down the left
you'll see all of these sub project
requirements that people came up with
and there's literally thousands this is
just a you know a screenshot of that and
then we weighted them and we said these
customer requirements how did they
impact the functional requirements and
what we got out of that was a cyst was a
thousands of customer requirements that
were weighted so we knew that which ones
were the most important to us we then
used these weighted scores to have the
engineers rank the different providers
based on that and so as they went
through their experimentation or their
discussions they could use the decision
matrix to rank them and they could say
this fitness provider fulfills those
this divider doesn't at the end when you
cross multiply everything out you have
tens of thousands of data points that
you can compare these providers with and
in our case GCP had over 50,000 points
they won by over 10 percent and by using
this matrix we tried to eliminate
people's bias and bias because they the
preferred one provider or another or
they only had experience with one
provider or another and we tried to
eliminate all of that and make this a
very quantifiable approach that we felt
good with that we knew that they were
going to support our requirements and
meet our business needs and so we're
moving moving very quickly that we ain't
we announced the partnership in December
that we're gonna move to migrate
everything out of our data centers to
GCP we're on a two-year timeline we
almost immediately migrated all of our
image serving off of the of Etsy into
GCP and lots of the lots of other sub
projects the machine learning training
infrastructure is now migrated to GCP
and so lots of these sub projects
are already in stuff but we're planning
on a full two-year migration to get all
of our systems out of there
Etsy web is the big one and so we're
trying to break that down into as many
small pieces as possible to move the
marketplace up to GCP and we of course
have to do this around the busy times a
year typically ecommerce coming company
where we have you know lots of lots of
traffic in the q4 around holidays and so
all of that has to be taking the
consideration and time into this but we
already have all of this running in the
cloud and we're doing load of
performance testing on that right now
and so that's how we're building up
confidence is replaying traffic against
the GCP infrastructure with the etsy web
marketplace running there and so that's
all that's going into the migration
stuff of this and so just to recap
before we take some questions you know
we're a global marketplace we really
really believe in our mission of keep
Congress human and that means everything
that we do has to follow that and that
means not only our engineering but the
way we host the way we build our
products all of this we have a very
strong engineering culture and we wanted
someone a partner that could could could
meet us there and really you know fit
within our culture we did this you know
made the decision and are doing the
migration by dividing it up into a
number of small projects utilizing that
decision matrix so that we have a
quantifiable decision then we can feel
good about and stand behind that we made
the right decision and migrated to GCP
really allows us to do this in a
sustainable fashion that they really get
where we're coming from in terms of
having 100% renewable energy and and
sustainably and really you know we found
I think someone that's proven to be a
great partner in the migration with us
[Music]